So, if you think about what we just discussed. Definitely one
of the causes was the increasing product complexity. Products were becoming more
and more complex and software was replacing more and more, what
was before, provided by hardware components.
Slow productivity growth was another problem,
because programmers could not keep up with the additional complexity of
the software that they had to develop. I would like to say
there was lack of funding for software engineering research because I'm
a software engineering researcher, but that was not one of the reasons
for the software crisis. Instead, it was
the rising demand for software. Again, more
and more software was being required and
more and more software was replacing hardware.